c'est un service une en sommes des êtres
humains je crois et notre espèce c est
patente
aujourd'hui nous envoyons en orbite des
hommes et des femmes nous décryptons le
chez nous pour rené des maladies par
centaines
nous explorons les fonds marins nous
allons un peu creusé pour du pétrole de
foin de c1 n'ont pas eu mal par le
plaisir des autres de trop sur les
chiffres histoire on a du mal à ne pas
cliquer sur le lien pour higuain plus
scandaleux mag' l'animal nous commettons
tous les jours des qualifs du petit
kadhafi en connaissance de cause
d'ailleurs quand on sait qu'ils vont
nous fera que b mais qu'on fait mais
quand même c'est la vie mais dans la
crasse avec ghazi est un peu cracra zia
publiera trazom et
l'étymologie est importante mais j'aime
beaucoup ça fait la différence car entre
le antoine a visité les actions entre la
théorie et la pratique et que vous
connaissiez la différence entre la
théorie et la pratique
andriana prendront fin d'ici
parce que c'est logique car elle est
partout dans le monde tous passés pro
logic je sois pas là aujourd'hui
symbole de la crains qu'il y ait raté
parce que voilà on sait bien en lapin de
l'exemple où on aura des occasions
qu'ils se comportaient comme il faudrait
et il tomba franck l'épousé gens que
vous appelez les reconnaître donc on a
des ailes du qu'alcool mai et cette
flore et sur les votes du pétrole fait
râler les excès vitesse on n'a plus un
peu et on sait bien qu'il faudrait pas
on a la classe vi nations c'est le
plaisir que l'on ressent quand on
repoussa demain ou après demain le fn
ont aujourd'hui on sait dabou devrait
pas on a repris les méchants tout c'est
bon on est resté en fait des remarques
on se savait at il pas des mouvements
chante on sait bien on a tort le silence
par un profond
et on a des emportements l'actuel où les
gens vont pas acheter des stocks de
masques chirurgicaux des stops que
j'allais en énergique ce qui serait
qu'on voit ce qu'on fait
l'épidémie va pas s'arrêter six rameurs
sont guéris plus non pas de vous
consoler à l'idée partagée pour protéger
et aider les plus fragiles
on a tout comportement stupide comme les
conférences y prépare la conférence la
veille au soir
on a notre portement terrible comme les
gens qui hésitent avec six des neuf
enfants assez pantois effrayante et
alors en fait on a les deux
scientifiques et médicales qui montrent
que les risques à ne pas vacciner les
enfants sont beaucoup beaucoup plus fort
que les laisse pas les vacciner on a
autre truc pas et risque on parle donc
mon avis d'adorateurs pour un conférence
tel sur un plateau comme ça et qu'on n'a
pas dirigé visuellement il était espéré
compte peut-être
il n'était pas sous le coup de 2 500
signalements la ville élue par des
désirs rocky soleil respectèrent
enseignants on à l'invs a dû ferrailler
et puis quand on l'a fait quand même
enseigne pour devrait s'excuser d'avoir
fait un bond en vigueur à partir de là
grazi c'est pénible y compris sur les le
plateau ted et ailleurs ailleurs ces
pays aux médias
indépendamment de qualité on est un peu
en pratique prenez par exemple
saint-augustin champ contre les tiques
briand qui savaient très bien ce qu'ils
savaient vouloir y avait du mal à
l'assumer dans ses confessions il a
écrit seigneur donne moi la chasteté et
l'incontinence mais ne veut pas de suite
ensemble le beauf lui il sait très bien
ce qu'il faut c'est avec un pan de sa
tout donc à ce soit zara attention ne
penseront pas immunisé contre la crise
et le fait de donner un nom à ce
phénomène
elle trace y ait razia donne l'illusion
avait compris un peu et qu'on domine le
sujet elle émet un sentiment de
puissance et de confort de dire content
et c'est ce sentiment qui va motiver des
gens à partager ses vidéos sur la
planète ans est partagé entre une
fonction partage mais jean même
sentiment est un peu trop peur parfois
sablera imprudente
imaginez vous voulez dire un astrologue
qu'ils se plantent parce que qu'il
éradique de la précession des équinoxes
d'equinox a donné raison
il se lève peut pas expliquer ce que ça
veut dire pour que la mène donc la
phrase si c'est bien mais le porte
monnaie c'est avant-hier un truc moi
j'ai le policier un petit peu
aujourd'hui on boit un coup de l'imam
on va apprendre à crasy par rapport à
l'indicé du climat réalisme ça date un
peu pour le climat et bien vous allez
subir un consensus scientifique qui
établit que le climat de la terre c'est
la vie d'un change de manière importante
manière rapide et c'est dû en grande
partie aux activités humaines moi j'ai
trois hématologue ont travaillé ces
belles manières vous compterez pourquoi
on sait que 30 ans tous les modèles
climatiques s'améliorent safin se
confirmer et va pousser des conclusions
qui montrent qu'il ya un consensus
scientifique c'est la recherche c'est
comme ça fait appel je sais pas égaux on
négocie pour tenir prêts quant à des
faits ce n'est qu'on le dit aussi pas
planter deux banderilles les débats sont
ici
tu es fini avant jantes rancune achats
chez décennies et à débat sociétal c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
dans tous ces faits par rapport à ce
qu'ont laissé savoir donc pour décider
et dépend de votre société
on se bat ce concept on veut prendre les
meilleures décisions possibles donc de
pair accrédite donc qu'est ce qu'on sait
c'est que si on continue comme ça à
exploiter les ressources que notamment
le fossile donc on va provoquer des
canicules et d'eelv en extrême on voit
déjà que ça arrive on va augmenter à des
applications
on va fondre les glaciers et les a
baptisés c'est triste vraiment la fin du
flop total à frost
enfin le pas la france quand ils font
ils valoir leur gré il ya les micro
organismes
il semble être pire que le koro
d'ailleurs on va bouleverser la
biodiversité
on va la fédé flux des instruments sans
précédent et de l'intensité de ça va
dépendre du temps qu'on va mettre à
réagir
ça c'est ce que nous savons à paris
légaux et si on le sait maintenant
qu'est ce qu'on préfère parce que de
faire ça dépend de ce qu'on pense des
conséquences du conseil on peut dire que
le plein d'un marché un micro mais on
peut dire que éventuellement on s'en
fout puisqu'on a inquiété des
conséquences qu'une fois sans que le
sourire alors revenir au mieux on est
bien comme une condition et donc que on
va essayer de faire quelque chose pour
reprendre après ses conséquences
également bon puisqu'on peut faire
quelque chose
alors du coup on passe à qu'est-ce que
comme on fait la passe
problème de l'avis motivé y ait des
choses dans la vie ils sont sympas à
croire et l'autre nous donc ça vous avez
le brocoli chou cause d'un verre sans
légumes c'est dégueulasse
et donc une idée j'ai dû y être qu'ils
seraient des places pour veut pas y
croire on se dit est ce que je suis
obligé d'y croire
un corner et puis l'autre côté on a une
idée vachement plus sympa qui d'humains
valeurs qui en ligne elle est là pour ce
que tu dis est ce que j'ai trois croix
mais c'est vrai la question maintenant
encore une sorte de mauvaise foi que
l'hypocrisie pas là pour ça et en fait
j'ai spontanément faire exprès lots
seulement motivé fait que à combats très
forts croire ça est très fort par ça
alors peut-être que c'est des vols est
donc ce seul henri iv nous poussera
peut-être de ne pas pouvoir faire ce
qu'on peut faire
or si on peut le faire contre le
laissait donc ce qu'on va faire
alors je vais vous faire une liste enfin
faisons les bulletins baisser la liste
pour notre exemple
en gros ce qu'on a à faire dit il faut
consommer des produits durables et le
sida font qu'on arrête de parler de coût
quand j'étais comme ça ce qui compose
les moins 10 ans et sasha grey personne
n'a mais c'est comme ça il faut
consommer plus de produits valent sur
local et de saison
parce que si on consomme le calme et
qu'il faut des grandes serres chaud
soleil du pétrole qui voudraient d
énergie moins chère bonnet pour par
rapport à ces thématiques nucléaire
c'est plutôt pas mal
je me dis que c'est ayant eu le désir la
plainte de lui son affaire car en gros
il ya plein de gens qui me pierre collin
celle ci est ce qu'on veut le faire à la
crasse il est là
elle fera si tu veux la paix on sait
bien et qu'on a ce problème
d'actualisation et diabolique
c'est un fait grave dans cette phase 1
c'est que l'être humain précieuse
récompense tout de suite maintenant
depuis 29 ans plus fort ou plus tard à
la rentrée ça avec le test du marche mal
au sedif honnête on est gamin tout petit
dans l'est mais sur une chaise et on
regarde un match laborieux lundi aux
gamins si tu fais ça c'est que tu ne le
mangent pas quand je reviens de chez un
marabout
il en sort on est gamin tout seul avec
son match va louer sa descente et son
désespoir
makina peu et son circuit de récompense
de cours à côté du requip et je le sais
et nous on est barré par le pas je crois
que c'est le terrain on veut te bouffer
un fautif à la prépa voilà est donc ce
polar jalouse c'est un exemple de choix
intertemporelle n'ai pas peur j'ai mal
que les trains de tableau les joueurs
temporel sur des destinations qui met en
jeu des arbitrages entre des coûts et
des bénéfices le vert à différents
moments
l'exemple classique c'est la frontière
un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras
compris des jeux soit quatre par l e le
climat évidemment tout ce qu'on va faire
à des conséquences non remontants donc
on se trouve avec un bail à long terme
et le cerveau ils veulent faire
raisonner à l'échelle du mouv rire de
nous ou du mandat électoral et on est en
plein moment des élections normales
c'est compliqué de dire aux gens qu'ils
vont chier pendant dix ans il faut pas
donc je vois la glace que on est face à
un une émotion avec les sacrifices
immédiats
c'est fou un an et puis des bénéfices
potentiels futurs
si vous peut-être si leur avis
maintenant vingt ou trente ans et du
coup le cerveau
il est alors la burie se résoudre à la
foule que c'est ce qu'a tout de joël
bats le baby bourré de on travaille sur
le team à y aller seul est vide il se
trouve que ça c'est du flan et si on
fait plein d'efforts et comprend le
monde meilleur pour rien alors ça a
l'air con il ya une partie du cerveau
qui se dit oui c'est possible que ça
parce que j'ai par exemple et pourquoi
coffret les efforts et dans ce cas on
est face au problème du paradoxe de
l'action collective c'est que
normalement les nombreux à avoir un but
commun on sait qu'on a intérêt à se
mobiliser
qu'est ce qu'on fait non magique c'est
par la logique ce refus des forains fait
pas pourquoi parce que quand les
bénéfices sont collectifs mais plus le
l'effort il est individuelle d'un type
de comportement va rappeler un f2 t1 et
briest un passager clandestin qui dit
moi je veux bien les bénéfices par
contre pour les espoirs paul me laisse
assez théorisé boniface et le sert un
comportement irrationnel à son échelle
mais qui lorsqu'on le met un peu de
temps avec vénérable vient à pratiquer
de la cre asie de la crise ont donc on a
fait de la jeunesse social qui
fonctionnait parce que si on a des
motifs en salle et qu'il faut pas qu'ils
s'installent et jean mais voilà qu'on
retrouve armés actifs à ce milieu donc
on pourrait mettre en place des
stratégies moque l'ingénierie sociale
qu'est ce que ces jeunes comme une
phrase c'est el principe take social
visant à faire évoluer les formes
d'actions individuelles et collectives
j'ai la broche coopérative démocratique
et participative et ça c'est sympa mais
ça ressemble beaucoup à la jambe et une
consentement qui elle est le résultat de
la propagande et de
de passe et ça s'est calmé - sera pas et
comme on sait pas distinguer les deux
logiquement quand on pratique ça les
formes de résistance
les gens sont pas d'accord parce qu'ils
ont le bac ça me plaît et c'est et c'est
relativement cohérent et logique de
résister à ça donc j'ai la solution
compliquée mais le problème je vois où
il est allé le pré visites très
précisément dans votre crâne
on est en signant le maintien vous il
est possible que le cerveau humain ne
soit pas l'outil adapté pour répondre
aux défis du climat ce que les symboles
d'un des suspects il répond à des
impressions passage de l'air fugace à la
désinfection les anecdotes à des rumeurs
tout ça il ya beaucoup d'espoir mais
pour acheter une analyse et souvent ça
devenait bon résultat mais ne sera plus
un problème de cette échelle là ça
marche pas très bien et donc le voilà
libre
ça va pas être facile et comme on est
tous des humains que moi je ne sais pas
je viendrai j'ai pas solution je vais
vous dire qu'il ya un problème est qu'on
va chier et moi je pourrais faire les
efforts personnellement si jamais je
savais qu'on peut tous pas de confiance
mais en gros or est-ce que la société
aujourd'hui nous donnent des gages que
l'on peut faire confiance au nez une
décision prise en entre nous pas sûr
donc tant qu'on n'aura pas ça et là les
discussions on va pas les assumer parce
que en fait c'est nous qui sommes à rien
de moi je n'ai pas là avant toi + moi je
suis quelqu'un belge et humain qui passe
trop quand elle fixe et qui à
procrastiner import sa conférence
etats-unis hier en pleine nuit
via ses confessions je suis agrati
moi même je sais que j'ai les défauts je
suis pas en train de vous dire c'est pas
grave et qu'on revient de l'arctique et
les défauts et je sais qu'elle a mon
échelle
incapable de faire les efforts
suffisants donc j'ai besoin s'en faisait
des temps collectifs aller aujourd'hui
le câble de comcast consignes à tous les
échelons et dont je viens de retrait
bien c'est vous
[Applaudissements]